christina vidal mitchell was just
18 years old when she landed the title
role on nickelodeon's sitcom
tyena
or you may remember the triple threat
from her other beloved roles in brink
mind getting lost mind if i kick your
butt and freaky friday he's not even
lucky he's not
he's not look he's totally looking i
think he's gonna talk to you shut up
were you like the rest of us crushing on
chad michael murray and eric von detten
uh yeah
[Laughter]
i was so boy crazy i just had crushes
all depressions we're going all the way
down memory lane
but first christina's got a new gig on
tv and this time
she's playing a mom 705.
how is it so early and we're already so
late where's my phone where's my phone
it's ringing shut up everyone shut up
[Music]
got it it's about their their marriage
it's about their family it's about how
they
get through every day because they were
these two
um just awesome people you know who were
ambitious
they felt like they were hitting on all
cylinders until they had children
parenting is hard enough
and then how your family when they mean
well
kind of can put more pressure on your
already collapsing world
but with but with the light of comedy
you're a woman who does it all you're
acting you literally gave birth four
days ago
you've got another daughter you've got a
husband
was this a relatable project before i
even read the script i was like
this is me i mean literally this is how
i feel about
parenting and being a mother it's just
like
a hot mess
you left me in the car
i'm so sorry it's okay you also left
your case
yeah she moved it what we really grew up
watching you
and this star who was you know an
adolescent
and now you're getting lead roles
playing
a mom does that blow your mind a little
is that wild
it's surreal it's like
it's bizarre i i in a lot of ways i
still
feel like that kid who's rollerblading
and like
playing guitar and like you know what i
mean and being in
nickelodeon like so sometimes i'm it's a
reality check like no no you're a grown
woman
well i can't let you go without taking a
little stroll down memory lane let's do
it
you're known for a lot of beloved
classics i'm curious which one
do fans approach you about the most
brink
freaky friday and then taina is the next
one
which project changed your life the most
taina it was the first time that i was a
lead
in anything and i had that much work to
do and that much responsibility i grew
a lot and matured a lot in a very short
period of time i had a lot of personal
uh ups and downs during that time
and then professionally it was like i
got to showcase more than one
part of my talent and i think that that
was sort of a it was a groundbreaking
role for me like i think it catapulted
me
into a lot of other work and opened up
different opportunities for me
can i ask you what's
being a teenager um and having
you know notoriety and having
responsibility like i didn't know how to
be a lead on a show
i didn't know how to in some ways behave
and be professional
and i had to learn that the hard way you
know i liked to party i liked to be out
i like to kind of do my own thing
sometimes i didn't have the best
attitude on set
and uh i had to learn the hard way kind
of the consequences of that behavior
on taina they actually came and talked
to me and they were like look
like the show is doing great and so for
that reason we want to pick it up
but there are some things you're gonna
need to change
i was just partying i was like late at
times
sometimes unprepared like my attitude
wasn't great i was exhausted and i was a
kid
trying to be responsible at work but
also
being a teenager and going through
normal teenager things right
and i always said after my experience
with tyena if i ever got a chance to be
a lead again
i wanted to do it totally different i
wanted to behave
differently i wanted to treat people
differently
and so yeah and so that that was
what i learned on there of all the
projects of your past
which one holds the most sincere spot in
your heart
taina would you consider doing a reboot
i know you're busy with united we fall
right now
the opportunity presented itself and you
could squeeze it into your schedule
would you do taina 2020
yeah heck yeah are you kidding me
i don't know what it would look like but
absolutely i would i've i've thought
about that many many times like
oh how many things i would do different
if i got the opportunity to do taina
again
can you give me a few
well i would work on my dancing for sure
i would for sure work on my dancing
i would want to focus on more that i
didn't focus on at that time
was the impact it had on not just latina
girls but
on little girls and on other ethnic
girls who were like
i loved turning on the tv and seeing
myself represented and i did not know
the importance of that or i didn't
understand it back then the way that i
understand it now
and so i don't know how but i would want
to somehow
like sew more into that if that makes
sense
you have any idea where she would be
today or where we would find her today
she would still be doing what she loved
she would probably be
still auditioning and still doing some
like
off-broadway theater but like in l.a
maybe a mom maybe
maybe a mom yeah i could see that hey
gabriella
ever get arrested for impersonating a
boy no
you my biggest grievance as a kid
was where is the brink sequel why didn't
you
bring sequel was that ever a
conversation
not that i was in on but it was a
conversation after our zoom
um reunion
eric was talking about like doing a zoom
like a brink reunion
and he's like let's do it like i don't
know if i can get on rollerblades again
you guys i got to be honest
after two babies no but would you be
down if
maybe gabriella's daughter joins
a league and that's how you're involved
in some capacity
i feel like gabriella would have a
school
i feel like she would have a daughter
who was
into rollerblading yeah i think that
would be great
she had the same shirt yeah but this
looks okay right it's like a style
yeah so it's cool no oh definitely
freaky friday
what was that experience like oh my gosh
it was so much fun
lindsay and i had so much fun yeah and
the whole cast we had a great time
we got to do like a month
or a month and a half of rehearsals
beforehand
that was so fun because i felt like i
was really in a band
and then getting to be on the house of
blue stage and perform
on that stage was like what is up with
you today
you act like you don't even care about
this band if it were any other night but
tonight whatever anna
when was the last time the two of you
spoke
i actually saw her at a concert it was
years ago though
i mean i'm i'm talking like gosh maybe
almost 10 years ago now
and um she had literally an entourage
like
a literal entourage of people
surrounding her and she was like
christina and she like reached out her
arm and i reached out my arm and they
all like
swarmed and pulled her away and that was
the last time i saw her
i mean so many misconceptions about her
you set the record straight you know her
personally you know you worked with her
yeah she is a very real
and down-to-earth person um
and i think that that got misunderstood
for a lot of other things
she had a lot of responsibility on her
not just professional for her age and i
think that
sometimes we don't realize how difficult
that can be
for a young person do you mean like in
terms of like you know helping with her
family
and just just life i mean
she just she had a she had a lot you
know she was a very independent
person for her age i thought i was like
wow i'm so
impressed like you're you're like an
adult if she sees this interview is
there a message you'd want to send i
truly i would just love to see the two
of you sharing the screen
uh oh my god i would love that
just lindsay
i wish we could hang out where are you
come over
let's go swimming and let's eat some
cheese and apples
she loved like cheddar cheese like a
cheddar cheese block and an
apple and she introduced me to that my
last hard-hitting piece of journalism
here
yes were you like the rest of us
crushing on chad michael murray and eric
von detten
uh yeah
[Laughter]
i was so boy crazy i had a crush i had a
press on
chad michael murray i had a crush on
eric von den i had a crush on
patrick levis who was also on brink like
i had a crush on the guy
who was our skating instructor i had a
crush
on the guy who um for freaky friday
taught us to play guitar like i just
i just had crushes all all the crushes i
have all these
things turned to fruition did any of
them amount in like a fling or a
relationship
oh no girl not one what happened
they were not they were not interested
in me i had a mustache i don't think
they were really into that
[Music]